Donald Trump absolutely dissembled during
the weekend, White House coronaviruses, press
briefings.
And I challenge you today to tell me what
on earth Donald Trump is talking about here.
He actually seems ill in this video.
He's he's not making any sense.
I cannot for the life of me, figure out what
Donald Trump is talking about.
But let's play it.
It's the stuff of horrors.
Back to the scene that you used to have, which
was, look, I could tell you about and I'm
not going to do it because I didn't want to
bring it up.
But I could tell you about events that took
place.
And I said things like, you'll never do that
again or you'll never do this again.
Or I don't really want to make sure the events
are want to mention which is supposed to be
doing because.
And, you know, one of them was so horrible.
I said a certain industry will be out of business,
never happen again.
Two weeks later was like nothing ever happened.
Hopefully we get rid of this.
We have tremendous talent appear and all over,
including governors.
That doesn't make sense.
There is nothing there.
There is no substance.
What Trump is talking about is impossible
to ascertain from what he is saying.
Look at a transcript of this.
It doesn't mean anything back to the scene
which you used to have, which was, look, I
could tell you about.
And I'm not going to do it because I didn't
want to bring it up.
But I could tell you about events that took
place.
And I said things like, you'll never do that
again or you'll never do this again.
Or I don't even want to mention the events.
I don't want to mention what you're supposed
to be doing because.
And, you know, one of them was so horrible.
I said a certain industry will be out of business,
never happen again.
Two weeks later was like nothing ever happened.
Hopefully we get rid of this.
We have tremendous talent up here and all
over, including governors.
I don't know what he's talking about.
This is not the way someone who is of sound
mind communicates with people.
Never mind on a daily basis for hours, day
in and day out, or the reporters just have
to sit there and wait for it to end and ask
their next question.
Here's another one from the following day,
which again makes absolutely no sense.
It's an unhinged and wacky rant attacking
the media as thousands of Americans per day
continue to die.
Sources say, you know, sources say, many sources
say means they have nobody and they make it
up OK.
And they have a few other type statements
that mean the same thing.
But sources say is the most often used expert
in The Washington Post, New York Times, especially
CNN, fake news, CNN.
They should really be mandated.
I mean, mandated to use a name if there's
a source user name.
So there is Trump demanding that journalistic
convention around sources.
Sources, of course.
An absolutely critical element of journalism
be thrown out and all sources must be named.
You can't have that.
You can't say sources here.
You can't have an anonymous source.
Of course, remember, anonymous sources typically
are anonymous to the public, but the reporter
knows who they are.
And Trump just continuing to do this thing
where he attacks the basic conventions of
journalism and press freedom.
And then Trump going on to talk about testing
and just how amazing and great everything
is and sort of promoting Corona virus tests
as if they're some new iPhone or something
like that that are just going to crush the
competition.
Take a look.
I don't believe the sources exist.
And I try and tell this.
You know, the beautiful thing about doing
these conferences is that we have tremendous
numbers of viewers and I'm able to reach the
viewers without having to go through fake
news where they make a good story into a bad
story.
So with all of that, it's been an incredible
period of time.
We've done a fantastic job with the talk of
other nations.
The leaders of other nations are calling us
for help.
They're calling us for equipment.
They're calling us for testing capacities.
Now, with the testing, we are going further.
Deborah's going to talk about that now with
the testing.
We have some other tests coming up that are
going to be, I think, phenomenal.
I think they're going to blow away everything
as soon as they come out and we're going to
get them out as soon as possible.
But I'd like to ask Dr. FERC's to come up
and say a few words about where we've come,
how far we've come, and more importantly,
where we're going from this point.
Because honestly, it's it's quite amazing.
Thank you very much.
That's the president of the United States.
If you can believe it.
And then the testing thing we're going to
do a deeper dove into testing tomorrow.
Remember that the test.
The thing is, is now a way to scapegoat governors
for Donald Trump.
Trump has been bragging for months about how
all that's happening with testing is because
of him and that we're testing the best and
we're testing the most in all of this stuff.
Now that Trump's talking about reopening and
numerous public health officials are making
clear we just don't have the tests to reopen
right now.
Trump is very quickly shifting and talking
about, hey, listen, these governors have to
test.
You know, I mean, we're doing what we can
here, but the governors really need to do
the testing.
The numbers right now are we're testing about
one hundred and fifty thousand a day.
Yesterday we tested, I think about one hundred
and sixty seven thousand.
That's the most we've tested in a day that
needs to more than triple to get us to a minimum
for reopening.
We need at least five hundred thousand tests
a day that we're doing now that are sitting
somewhere.
Five hundred thousand a day minimum.
One roadmap says we need a million tests today
to reopen.
One roadmap says we really need 22 million
a day to reopen, which is a crazy number.
But that would let you test the whole country
on a rolling basis every two weeks.
In any case, Trump now starting to shift the
blame on testing to governors.
And then lastly, here's Trump trying to humiliate
a reporter whose question he doesn't like
by interrupting and insisting the guy tell
him who he works for and flippantly telling
the guy, yeah, keep reading your question
of everything.
Get the American people don't understand why
you're unwilling to use the awesome powers
of your presidency to make American companies
manufactured.
And also the testing equipment that you implement
implement your recommendation.
Who are you?
I was TMZ recommendations for and what is
time?
Media news.
What?
My name is Doug Christian taught me.
News media has to keep reading your question.
So increasingly you're seeing networks just
not carrying the full press briefings.
And it's tough because new policy is announced
that these press briefings pretty often.
So here's my view on it.
The Mike Pence part is worthless.
Pence goes up there.
He never announces any new guidelines.
He praises Trump for his leadership.
He lists the number of masks that air bridge
flights are ordering or whatever.
I mean, it's absolutely meaningless.
So my policy now, it increasingly has been
and now it will be on a hard and fast basis.
I will be muting the Mike Pence part.
It's worthless as the Trump part.
I do the best I can to fact-check so that
when Trump lies about testing or this or that
fact, I try to instantly rebut it so that
at least my audience understands how the disinformation
is being formulated.
And then we have the portion where we hear
from doctors, which is actually useful to
the extent that the doctors are telling us
the full truth.
Sadly, Dr. Bourke's is increasingly a vector
of mild disinformation as well, very clearly
placating Trump in ways that go above and
beyond the sort of mere collegiality of Dr.
Foushee.
Dr. Brooks is actually becoming a perpetuator
of some of Trump's disinformation.
And then you have the question session, which
I do actually find interesting to see what
reporters ask.
But that's where we are right now in terms
of the press briefings.
And as you can see, very bizarre things are
taking place at these press briefings.